noria is worried about her family who
have been sleeping on the streets
outside kabul airport for four days
they called me they text me what should
we do we should go home if we go home
they will kill us
those messages came just hours before
the explosion
all the kids with us and we are
spending our time and this is the things
that
it's a very hard time very tough as
minorities from the hazara community
they are being targeted by the taliban
noria's sisters say they have already
been attacked
i'm very worried about them i i know if
they go back to home
they will kill them because they are
living in hazara area
and they can't go outside they can't go
to work frisana is only 10 but is all
too aware of the dangers facing her
family they give us threats because we
just hazard and they say like we're
going to kill you if you don't leave
here and we're going to kill you because
your hazard and stuff
they are among thousands in the uk who
are desperate to help their loved ones
we are all british citizens and we are
trying to
do our best to get our families over
here
some are mindful they may be living on
borrowed time any minute can happen
anything in afghanistan at the moment so
my hope is i hope i hope my father my
two sisters can come to england
because i have house i can look after my
family the only one thing
i i hope
british people can bring my family to me
they want them to get out like neymar
tulla and his young family the 36 year
old is achieving scholar sponsored by
the uk government to study here now
quarantining after his flight early this
week he says his ticket to freedom is
bittersweet i am one of the luckiest
person i believe in my country
with all the unluckiest upgrades we and
all the unluckiest life we have had
through
i wish i do something for my country i
wish i did something for my entire
world because we live under one human
being so yes i am delicious
many will need more than luck as the
last flights leave kabul the ones left
behind are those with nothing left to
lose ash nahari skylers